[Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  language Jarvis what's the view from  upstairs the central building is  protected by some kind of energy shield  strucker's technology is well beyond any  other hydra base we've taken Loki's  scepter must be here Strucker couldn't  mount this defense without Lomas  and long last is lasting a little long  boys  think we lost the element of surprise no  one else is gonna deal with the fact  that cap just said language I know  just slipped out  [Music]  who gave the order to attack Herr  Strucker is the Avengers they landed in  the forwards the perimeter guard  panicked they have to be after the  scepter can we hold them the Aventis  deploy the rest of the tanks concentrate  fire on the weak once a hit to make them  close ranks in the verge of greatest  breakthrough and let's show what we've  accomplished send out the twins it's  just hard man that's what they signed up  for  my men I can hold them  you